hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar heterologous protein engineering
and characterization of native
regulatory elements in e coli using
massively parallel crispr editing
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and bro excuse me
and brought to you by inscripta to learn
more visit inscripta.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
at the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr tyson shepard microbial engineering
applications manager at inscripta
dr shepard you may now begin your
presentation
hi thanks so much for the introduction
and thanks to all of you for joining me
today
for this upcoming webinar
in this webinar i'll be taking you
through
a recent application that i've been
developing while i'm in scripture
um
so this application is leveraging the
unscripted onyx platform to be able to
make protein
modifications and improvements to
functions of proteins that have been
stably cloned into the genome of e coli
in this case and
then being able to create an engineered
variance of that protein and to be able
to modify expression
so as mentioned i'm a senior scientist
in the applications development group
and the script i've been here for about
a year
and
so yeah let's uh let's jump in and
so i think we all know that of course
evolution is a driving force uh
behind being able to diversify new
activities which
saccharomyces cerevisiae
where you can actually design your
mutations specifically to these uh
to the genome
uh either customized with hydraulics
proteins as you'll see later
or with the native genome directly
you then
ultimately will get to order those
libraries and then in a few weeks you'll
receive a consumable kit that you load
to the instruments
and the instrument works in an automated
way where
it will then
manufacture a pool of cells that in
aggregate contain the designs that
you've
designed
on that portal
that engineered cell is then taken
forward to do
all sorts of fascinating phenotyping
that's where you can
stretch your legs on what you can do
with
hundreds to
tens of thousands of different variants
in the library pool
and
after your
particular phenotyping assays
you can take that back to the
inscriptive resolver
to be able to connect back the phenotype
to the genotype and that's really the
workflow that we're going to walk
through today with the hydraulics
protein expression
it's the inscriptor offering here the
best way to kind of think about it is
previously
if you wanted to design a number of
variants what you would typically do is
separate those out into a micro tighter
plate
and then
do your
do your crisper gene editing or a genome
additing on those individual
wells within that and grow those up in a
simulated fashion
we've introduced the
single guide rna to make the cuts and
then of course the donut dna to
make the
repair happen
uh we're kind of
changing the way to think about that
because
we have a barcoding system that allows
you to be able to track
a cotton and stoner dna delivery to an
individual cell
and so ultimately
we have in aggregates the
cell itself being
behaving as the partition instead of the
well on the microtina plate
that
allows you to be able to
realistically track from hundreds to
tens of thousands of different
edits in an individual library to be
able to
screen them or select from that pool
of all of them
so as i mentioned the
number of edits and the type of edits
that you can make is
you can think of
substitutions
or insertions of up to 63 base pairs or
deletions up to the the same size
in either non-coding regions which lie
outside of the coding sequences and here
you might think of targeting
transcription factor binding sites or
promoter
promoter sequences or ribosome binding
sites for example
we also have the capabilities in the
designer to target the coding regions
and that really
allows you to
dive into being able to do saturation
mutagenesis
and gene knockouts and or truncations
for example
and so it's really up to your
imagination at that point of being able
to
port over new biology
to to engineer it to to your desire
so
um
just to give you an overview of
um the
system is
with the initial hosts on the initial
offering that the hosts that we're
supporting are e coli and saccharomyces
or vca
we have a standard set of
strains
which are based on for e coli mg 1655
and for technology
2 c and cpa
uh
the genome targets are both codeine and
non-coding regions
in that genome and then also
hydraulicist sequences that are
introduced into the genome so a custom
type genome
the
design library size
for e coli is from 100 designs up to 10
000 designs and for saccharomyces or vca
it's from 100 designs up to six thousand
designs
and uh to keep in mind about the actual
designs that could be made
is that um
you will have the capability of making
one edit per cell but in aggregate it
will contain all of the designs that
you've pushed to it it can be insertion
solutions or substitutions from one
base pair up to 63 base pairs and on a
typical library composition on a typical
run you would
see greater than 90 percent of the signs
covered through sequencing
and with an edited cell population of
between 15 and 75 of your cells being
edited
the
time to carry out this
particular
task is
uh it takes approximately three weeks to
be able to receive the consumer goals
and an on instrument run is about two to
four days and the hands-on time is
pretty much less than an hour
to be able to
load the consumables and press go
so that's been a tremendous savings and
something that i'll highlight through uh
this webinar is is the time savings for
doing uh
protein engineering
so i show here now that now that you
have in your mind with the unscripted
onyx platform uh has its capabilities i
show here a number of different possible
application areas that we've been
interested in but i also think that
generally that that will be impacted
across the community
um so i reference here in in strain
engineering instead
this opens new doors in metabolic
engineering and strain optimization for
allowance of
expression of toxic cells toxic proteins
or
or
or other small molecules that would
inhibit growth
also engineering hydraulicist pathways
so as
as larger and larger dna becomes
engineered within the genome that
becomes more accessible to engineering
with the onyx system
uh we also generally
have interest in
and seen interest in antibiotic
resistance and applications to be able
to develop
and understand routes of new antibiotic
resistance
there's of course
questions around evolution and achieving
new enzymatic functions by modifying
uh
enzymes based on evolutionary
characteristics
and then uh
separately there's you know
really rich research that's going on
regulatory networks and being able to
understand
uh the the actual causal interactions
that take place within a cell signaling
cascade all of these are accessible now
with the scriptonics platform and so it
does see the question as to how would
you use
this type of platform if you have the
capability of making
uh tens of thousands of different
variants within a within a library pool
to test hypothesis
so we we generally think in terms of
breaking down the workflow into two
different uh possible workflows
one is a pooled selection type approach
where we take the edited cell population
and we want to interrogate the entire
population and see its behavior so there
we might be looking for
enrichment in a
small molecule growth inhibitors and so
i
encourage you to go out to look at other
webinars
that we've done previously that have
talked about this pool based approach
and the selection mechanism and the
route that you would take through
phenotyping on
selections
but as separate route is
equally as interesting as this
singulation of colonies and looking at a
screeners workflow so in that case you
would
take your edited cell population
and separate them out into
isolates and then be able to test those
isolates for
new and novel functions
and that's the that's the workflow that
i'm going to highlight
for us in today's webinar
um so in that uh
in in that route what you would
typically do you're not selecting for a
population in this case
necessarily what you might be doing is
looking for a particular feature the
thing you would want to drive back into
sequencing to be able to connect that up
with the
genotype that you generated
and that allows you to be able to
connect that phenotype back to
a genotype where you can really like
stretch your legs on learning new things
from the biology
i'm going to highlight two application
areas that use that
isolate workflow
the first areas
is a small molecule production so
testing variants for being able to
improve overall production
in this case of lysine
so of course
with e coli
licensing of interest is
one of them a number of different small
molecules that can be
generated in e coli
for industrial use
but this is really a vehicle of showing
the power
of the onyx platform to be able to
really expand the
amounts of
biosynthesis that can take place when
you properly engineer a chassis
for production of that molecule of
interest
so there's really three different
scopes that you can look at in addition
of course it is at the protein level
each of the biosynthesis steps
realistically occurs at the active sites
of the enzymes that carry out the
synthesis reactions
so that's where the
magic of saturation mutagenesis and
those active sites can uh take place
the next level up are the pathways that
are responsible so it's not just going
to be about the
individual pathway of the biosynthesis
the proteins that are interacting
the active sites of each of those
biosynthesis
proteins but also the
the pathways that feed into that
biosynthesis
so for example uh those which would
otherwise go off into methionine and
threatening synthesis
those also uh are valuable targets
because they allow for the intermediates
to not be diverted away from the
production of the small molecule
and then to think more expansively
is
what can you affect on a genome to also
be able to improve production and these
are often things where you don't really
even know what necessarily what the
connection is at the start it's
exploratory to be able to identify
different proteins across the entire
genome that are responsible for
improving the overall production these
might have to do with toxicity of the
small molecule it might have to do with
being able to get energy
supplied to the biosynthesis pathway
etc etc so
really it's at that point is um is that
the horizon of being able to modify
the chassis to be able to be perfect for
the small molecule that you're producing
so for lysine
uh what we
did was a
screen of what ended up being 18 000
different isolates that we screened so
this relied heavily on a rapid fire mass
back
to be able to identify the production
across the all of these different
screened isolates
so the way that we
got to
to build up such a massive library to
test
was
we established a knockout library
genome-wide docket library and each of
those knockouts took place in two
different ways um
it's nearby to the start codon and then
just a little bit further in but still
stopping early terminating early
in
every protein
in the entire
e coli genome
secondly
on the
right side of the
left figures the promoter libraries so
i've talked about these in previous
webinars um
this is a a pretty
fascinating concept of putting a
constitutive
promoter in front of
every
coding sequence in the entire genome and
so we built a ladder of
weak to strong promoters to be able to
test
how much of an impact those promoters
would have
across the entire genome and then in the
center point are they
all the edits that were made targeting
to the specific pathways and so that's
really
a lion's share of the edits for this
library 174 000 uh different designs
remains on uh that were targeting the
actual pathway
and here it was really um targeting
pretty broad
broadly all of the genes that were
that were involved in that lysine
biosynthesis pathway
and the diverting pathways
um
and so then as i mentioned we had a
total of being able to synthesize is we
ended up
totaling
uh 24 different libraries that were
generated
and
that in total
and aggregate the entire pool size that
we were testing was over 200
uh designs
so we really needed that high throughput
uh
type system so in this case we relied
heavily on less spec
for pathway engineering that that
central library that had that
lion's share of edits there's 19 total
lysine biosynthesis pathway genes that
were targeted in addition to that
there's 20 transcription factors that
are responsible for interacting with and
ensuring expression of these
uh pathway genes
and so all of these were
targets then for site saturation
unigenesis and being able to
neutrogenize the sites
uh
it turns out that
we were able to by apply that screening
campaign identify 138
heads
that improve the production on the first
round of our testing
so the improvements that we saw from
that
mass spec were
from anywhere from
twofold up to a thousand fold over the
wild type
so we already saw substantial
improvement even by one round of
meditating on the onyx workflow
um
so it really was that
capability of being able to
have access to all of these different
variants in a very rapid way
so all of these
can be generated on the
encrypted designer software
and then you would receive these various
libraries and be able to
load them to the instrument literally
within
weeks of the initial
hypothesis
that you have you're to the point where
you have a pool of cells that have all
of these different possibilities in it
and then it's just left up to your
screening campaign to be able to dive
into that cell pool and isolate out the
the
the
the best the the the winning uh
variants in that population
um so we really have that uh kind of
rapid turnaround that's unprecedented in
our fields and that's one of the things
that makes me so excited about this
platform
so
certainly like i have a background in
structural biology and so i think of
of these often in structural details
and a one particular protein that we
really saw a number of interesting hits
on is this dapa proteins this is a
central or key enzyme of the lysine
that's exist pathway
uh we
it it it has this feedback inhibition by
the lysine production
and
so it was hit hard with this library
amongst the other enzymes
by a site saturation
by
unigenesis library class b the enzyme
and
one thing that's a note about this
enzyme the daphae enzyme is that it's
known in literature to actually have a
a variant like glutamic acid e4 to three
that is known to improve production and
we actually ended up capturing that hit
in our screening campaign uh which we're
always excited about finding these
literature relevance uh captures uh
because it's it's
quite a quite a nice thing to be able to
to connect that back with the larger
findings
and so we saw it secondary to this
mutation
is that by putting this constitutive
strong promoter in front of the
cafe gene we're able to further
uh enhance that production of mice
so those were a couple of hits that we
pulled out so we as you can see from
this plaque the fold improvements over
the wild type in just the first round of
editing so this is this would take like
you're thinking in terms of like one two
one and a half months of the initial
idea to get to the point where you've
got the 600
uh 900 fold improvements over the wild
type uh so there's a couple of examples
that occurs in the first round that's
that literature example of the dapp a
with glutamic acid modification but then
there's also
this constitutive promoter that was put
in front of the dape and then we saw
almost a thousand-fold improvement by
putting the constitutive promoter in so
you have to be wondering what happens
when we start
stacking these modifications on top of
each other
this is what we uh what we saw with the
second round of editing so we took our
winner from the first round of editing
at dape with a high strength uh promoter
and
built on top of it at yet another uh
round of editing so this would be an
additional if you had the reagents
ordered
or even if you're stacking on top
you're looking at
two months three months to get from
original hypothesis now getting ten
thousand fold improvement of production
of the small molecule so combined and
accurate when putting that mutation
together we see this uh
huge increase of
so that's kind of the winner to take
into uh the next round the round three
uh attitude so we take the winner that
has that mutation we push forward with a
genome-wide um
screen of
of hits this happens in the in the
pathway itself we we captured one where
it had uh
another constitutive promoter the j23
100
in front of this glmt
protein that further guides
it got us to a grand total of 14 000
fold improvements
uh
over the course of you know
several months
from start to to to to having this
enormous
e coli that could produce substantial
amounts of the lysine
so that was um
an exciting story and again i want to
emphasize that that's a vehicle for uh
or or a layout of uh how it could affect
your research uh so if you're interested
if
you have interest in small molecule
production
uh imagine what you could do with
harnessing this technology to be able to
build the chassis of balance the
specific small molecule that you're
interested in
so i want to talk about um
now like the the the core of the talk
which is the hydraulics protein
engineering
um so in this case this is about protein
optimization using the onyx system so we
just got done talking about how we've uh
we could manage to see you know massive
improvements of production using the
onyx system
to be able to capture
the a
and modify a pathway for production
but we also want to stretch our legs i'm
thinking about what if we want to put in
a hydraulicist pathway or in this case
produce a hydraulics protein
so the protein of choice here
is a fairly simplistic model system
it's a gfp
and
um
what i want you to think about is
the uh
the aspects once again of how this
actually applies to your own research
when when i talk about gfp here i'm
laying out uh what can be done with
multiple different proteins
for industrial use cases or therapeutic
design uh
designs is generally applicable uh type
of workflow and that's why i thought it
was so interesting to get it out to
to others
so the workflow for the hydrologist
protein engineering um starts from of
course generating and doing a qc step on
the initial strain so that initial
strength
and then that gets loaded up uh the the
final gen bank
the genbank that includes that
hydraulicist protein gets loaded up into
the scripted designer portal
which then is able to parse out the
genbank file and allows you to be able
to begin making edits on the protein of
interest or on the entire genome
that the protein is in
and so that's how you come to your
design libraries where that's that
inscriptive designer where you get to
interact with your genome
you take those design libraries and get
a pool um you ultimately get the
consumables to get loaded to the
instruments the instrument gives you a
pool of cells that in aggregate contain
all those designs
and then it's off to the races with
phenotyping so in this case i relied
heavily on that to can plate reader for
being able to look at fluorescence
you take those back to sequencing be it
with uh sequencing the library or
sequencing the individual isolates and
then those get taken into the
inscriptive resolver
platform which can process out that data
and allows you to go back just like we
did with the lysine production allows
you to go back and design make new
designs now with your your your new high
performing uh protester enzyme of
interest
so the way that
i built this was
uh not entirely different than of course
what's been reported in literature to
co-op the crispr based system and
combine that with the main directory
combination to be able to insert gene
length dnas in this case i use the mad
seven i use the inscript as
uh kind of um
almost like
kind of like an open source crispr
enzyme because you have access to it
in the novel kind of you know we provide
the sequence for it we provide uh
readily available for
for research use cases
and here
i applied that system to be able to uh
build the genomic uh build the pathway
into the genome and so this is as i
mentioned
super folder gfp
i chose that for the high fluorescence i
also put in front of the
sfgfp
j23 102 constitutive
high strength promoter it's not the
highest strength for promoter flights um
but it's certainly a
a strong promoter i built this um the
double-stranded dna template the pcr
template with 55 nucleotides of flanking
homology sequence
around the cut site
the pamp site was chosen from the mad 7
typical sequence the crispr rna
sequences provided
so
i kind of custom built that particular
cut site to allow for integration of the
sfgfp
the
gfp sequence itself is
based on the
super folder gfp
i
modified the gene sequence itself to be
slightly at rich
so it ended up with a 45 gc content
and then i also removed uh
kai sites and
and common restriction enzyme sites as
well as
ensured that there would be plenty of
mad seven pm sites distributed across
the
gfp sequence and then all that was
terminated with the t0 terminator
so this is one standard
uh approach this crispr based approach
certainly there's other amenable options
for building out
your hydraulicist protein including
using antibiotic markers that can be
looped out or left in
or
oxtrophic markers
especially of course widely used in use
for building
building
pathways so then the next
question is where do you get the protein
optimization variants from
and here
um
you can
go about this any number of ways so
being able to look into a whole catalog
of different variants so you can digest
those from
those insertion solutions and snips are
what you're looking for
you can type into regulatory data and
databases that contain that regulatory
information
you can look at evolutionary trees and
strain variants
so comparing say different strains of e
coli and looking for
snips or insertions of deletions between
them to be able to pull out the feature
that you want
to have
you can do that down to the enzyme scale
so looking at evolutionary variants of
enzymes or strain variants of specific
enzymes of interest
you can also use structure
guided approach to generating variants
so you can look at the active sites and
be able to identify residues important
for
in the active sites and be able to do a
variant library with those
uh another good way is to look at
published enzyme or protein variants and
so that's kind of the approach here it's
kind of a combination of several but i
leveraged fp base
which is a database of fluorescent
protein
variants and it's got a fantastic
catalog of all sorts of
great information about fluorescence uh
excitation and emission data and even
more like quantum yields and so forth it
says this rich data set
and what i did was i took an alignment
that super folder gfp against
many other
gfps in the same clades place
for
identifying hot spots of mutations
that cause some difference in the
spectral characteristics
and if the mutation shows up in multiple
instances then i call that a hot spot
and that then gets moved into a
saturation unigenesis library
so this is a pretty targeted library of
against these hot spots with saturation
in genesis so it's all 19 other you know
possible amino acids
against each of these evolutionary or
ovarian hot spots
across the protein and so in aggregate
i had 723 designs in total
that then i took forwards through the
entire onyx workflow
with those 723 designs so i ran that
through the onyx workflow
uploaded
that data by using the
edit
identification analysis on the
unscripted resolver
and
that showed that i had
about 66
editing
in my pool so
um
in this case we're calling that an edit
such that uh approximately
when pulling out a cell uh there's a
like a 66 chance that that cell is going
to contain an edits in this case
uh so that's not saying per design
that is saying that in aggregate there's
66
edited cells in your population
and then we use other metrics to be able
to identify
you know how how likely your design is
we have a rich data set that plays in
through the inscript that you can
identify uh through the encrypted
resolver platform
for being able to identify how many
cells to screen etc etc based on the
actual metrics that we get from from the
data
so we were very happy with
this it turned out that the metrics
looked extremely
good for this
library
very much
ready to carry forward so all of that
happened that that design step took you
know a couple of days coming out of fp
base
pushed into the inscriptive designer
which was you know within a few minutes
you get your designs back that meet your
specifications
and then a few weeks later i got my
consumables
and all of this occurred
very rapidly within two to three weeks
uh i was off often running on
phenotyping
so right away when plating out for
uh cfus i could see
a wide variety of different colored uh
colonies on the plates
so it was you know i already had a
notion this was going to be a rich data
set i was
quite excited
about that i
picked colonies
attempting to be somewhat agnostic on
the color of the colony
when picking
and i grew those up over the course of
24 hours
washed them in minimal media and then
diluted them down and then it will maybe
get to do a fluorescent screen rod
so that was in a tea can plate reader i
chose 192 colonies
and then i screened each of the 192
colonies of
three different excitation and emission
wavelength pairs
uh so i base these
these pairs
on blue fluorescent protein
excitation emission peaks
fluorescence
gfp
peak excitation emission
and yfp peak excitation emission
so i was able to
rapidly screened using this uh three
different
hypothetical fluorescence peaks to be
able to pull out if there was any
variation in the actual spectral
characteristics
any of those
that were different from
uh normal fluorescence i then did a full
spectral scan on a full excitation
emissions
scan on
and
what i found was that
there was this other fantastic
distribution of
fluorescences so there were
what's plotted here
is the fluorescence uh intensity
on the y-axis is when excited at 510 and
years of the yfb excitation
and on the x-axis is the gfp excitation
emission plotted the intensity of
fluorescence
so the wild type
super folder gfps all kind of clustered
arounds as you might expect expect and a
number of the colonies had to totally
disrupted fluorescence in gfp and yfp
channels and some had
disrupted gfp fluorescence but
substantial yfp fluorescence
and so that indicates that the spec that
the um that the excitation and measure
emission wavelengths at peak
have probably shifted
and there was one in particular that
really caught my eye it was pretty far
out in the gfp channel it's about 1.5
times more
bright than v
um than the the wild type super folder
gfp
and i should note
that all of these are adjusted on the od
600s um
absorptions
so uh they have been adjusted for the
amount of cell content
so that uh that really far out spot i
highlighted here with an exclamation
point that that's that's
that was a great finding because i i was
pretty excited that we found this higher
intensity
of variance
so as i mentioned
the inscriptive resolver makes it
trivial to be able to take all of that
content that you just gathered from your
phenotype and go back to the genotype so
through that
um
through the the sequencing pipeline we i
took that to
i i also did sanger sequencing just for
for the excitement of it but i took all
of those colonies back through illumina
sequencing i loaded the fastqs up to the
inscriptive resolver and was able to get
the identification of every one of these
variants
of
and be able to connect back from a
phenotype to genotype uh in a remarkably
easy way
and a couple of cool variants showed up
so it was the improved intensity that
was uh that was uh very exciting to see
and that turns out to be um in super
bowl or gfp
uh it's known that this is a critical
one of the critical residues uh
phenology that's at position 145
and it turns out that the mutation that
i pulled out with the improved intensity
was a mutation of that phenylalanine 145
to methionine
showed this
this intriguing intensity i also pulled
out a number of those that had disrupted
fluorescence it turns out that when i
checked on the
blue flask of protein channel that was
excitation 380 animation of 445
it turns out that a number of those
colonies while disrupted in the green
flesh and protein channel
uh were actually
quite active in the blue fluorescent uh
with blue fluorescence and so taking
some of those colonies back to
sequencing
several of those colonies identified as
the tyrosine 66 to histidine this is a
common well-known mutation
for generating a blue fluorescent
protein so is that that literature that
that kind of
almost uh
just a really good feeling when you've
connected back to literature and unknown
variants
so that ended up with the 375 excitation
and 440
emission peaks
with that single point mutation
so now that we have this uh improved
intensity
of
f 145 to m of mutation i wanted to carry
that forward for an additional round uh
editing
not dissimilar from that story that i
was telling you about
the lysine production
and on the second round i picked up a
whole other set of variants that were
interesting so if you seem to have a
moderate increase in fluorescence
but there were a lot that clustered
around the wild type
now wild-type
f-145 to m fluorescence there were the
pool that got disrupted but then there
were a couple of columns that really
spiked off
the charts on the the yfp
and one of those in particular had great
fluorescence so that's a
novel yfp variance based on the
f145 to m
that was carried forward so it shifted
from the 480 nanometer excitation to 510
nanometer
emission wavelength that shifted to
508 excitation and 522 emission
so it really turned out to be
this nice bright
yellow fluorescent protein
and all of this was able to like i
mentioned
all of this was able to be carried
forwards in you know a matter of weeks
uh from the start of this
so separately from this uh i have an
interest in whether or not you can
actually screen tuning the
gfp expression itself
so still looking at the locus
if we were to swap out or substitute in
instead of that
j23102 promoter we substituted in 50
base pairs in a
that are in front of every
transcriptional start site that was
annotated in the eco psych database
so we swap out all of the um
from the j23 102 considerable promoter
with every promoter in the entire e coli
genome
and separately make the lab make the
library where we swap out the shine
delgarno sequence that's built in to the
gfp
locus
and swap out the 20 base pairs prior to
every coding sequence so ideally
capturing or hopefully capturing every
ribosome binding site in the entire e
coli genome as well
so both of those together are four
thousand flexity
so in aggregate you get eight thousand
plex d library
and here again by uh screening uh
individual colonies uh you can imagine
ways that this can be made to be very
high throughput with uh fluorescence
activated sorting but just screening out
individual colonies i was already able
to pick out some interesting things
where
the control
value
but none of the
native promoters or ribosome
ribosome binding sites we're able to hit
that control
amount like we've really chosen the
synthetic system
that should have extremely high
expression and it's living up to its
expectation but what's fascinating is
that we get to catalog a number of
different promoters and ribosome binding
site strengths by looking across the
entire library of data and we can
organize those out into
what's the highly expressing promoters
medium-tier expressing promoters and
lifestyle binding sites and and
really quite low or inactive now this
could be like annotation issues or it
could be feedback mechanism issues
so there's probably you know multiple
feces worth of data that's uh that's
contained within this type of library
this is the type of thing that you can
have in in the palm of your hand uh once
you get that that cell pool um ready to
go so i kind of broke up these
high medium and low tiers of promoters
and ribosome findings i eat strings and
really we start to see some kind of
interesting features to it is that
there's a number of these that were
pulled out that were chaperones uh and
that are involved in
core metabolism of e coli there's even a
few uncharacterized proteins that find
their way into the mix
um
and so certainly uh
we see this
uh
this broad spectrum of ribosome buying
sites and promoter strengths and
you know i'm i'm still quite excited to
dive a lot deeper into this particular
library i'm just keenly interested in
seeing how a fluorescent sorting might
give a whole population of information
about all of the different promoters and
episode binding sites that would be
accessible in such a campaign
um but i'm just giving you here like you
know the the workflow where i'm able to
to pull out this interesting information
that that's that
can really identify how these promoters
are
functioning
and
and using a fluorescent screen
so really the
objective here is to show you that you
know the creation of libraries of cells
with greater than thousands of diverse
phenotypes has never been easier
uh that enscripted designer is just an
elegant
solution to being able to interact with
your genome to generate
novel variants
um and that type this is now like being
able to do site-directed unigenesis at
the genome scale to being able to make
modifications to protein to be able to
carry out saturation mutagenesis on a
protein on a genome at with precision
engineering
just
has never been possible before like this
and the other thing that i wanted to
highlight
is that this was done over the course of
several weeks
so the workflow here is just as simple
if not simpler than doing a plasma based
approach
and the key outcomes that i get from it
is that this protein is stable on the
genome i know exactly what's in the
genome uh i know exactly what's
the copy number the tunability of it
and
it gives me a whole new aspect for being
able to do that precision engineering of
the protein
i kind of throw it to you now so
at the scale of six to ten thousand
different edits per library of trackable
designs
with that
15 to 75 percent edited cells in the
population
uh all within a benchtop
platform that has integrated software is
that what could you do with this the
power of this instrument you know if
you're interested in small molecule
production
you're interested in pathway
optimization or protein
production and previously i've given
webinars about uh applications to
laboratory evolution and raising
tolerance to small molecules the
application areas are endless and so i'm
really excited
to
to see what what you'll be um
doing with this powerful technology
so thank you very much again for joining
me and i look forward to answering any
questions that you have
all right thank you dr shepherd for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question
is what are the benefits of doing on
genome modifications rather than the
plasmid based optimizations of the same
type
i think that's a great question um
so
the benefits kind of weigh
in mainly on what your current workflow
is but
for a lot of purposes um historically
plasmids have been used for protein
optimization and making side directive
mutagenesis because that was
the available technology but often those
findings would then have to be go
through subsequent
transference to
the genome when when scaling up for
production for example
what the
onyx platform really allows us to do is
to bring all of the
technology that comes from
side directive mutagenesis or or being
able to
access
all of the
landscape of
amino acid changes and so forth but
directly on the genome
what that translates to is a very rapid
way of being able to get consistent
reliable production off of the genome
and any changes that are made to the
genome are directly available then for
subsequent scale up rather than having
to go through an additional
you know six months to a year of
of technology transfers as the
mutations that write down the fighter
transfers back to the genomic expression
uh so there's a number of
you know
achievable
um powerful uh uh uh
uh methods of of editing on the genomes
that are now available through the onyx
platform
all right thank you dr shepard the next
question what type of optimizations were
used for the gene insertion
yeah
uh
so when we've been doing protein
production applications uh this and then
i also encourage we have some
uh webinars out about
optimization of an enzyme cbh1 and in
both cases
um when putting them into the genomes is
the kind of the the first thing we think
about is where to actually uh place them
in the genome and the workflow to use so
we were using a uh mad seven approach to
entering into the genome for the actual
sequence optimizations
we think about
what promoter to use and is that
promoter sequence
orthogonal to the genomic dna
we think about of course the ribosome
binding sites and and in this case as
you saw
we kind of had a pretty high expression
of gfp that's usually a good place to
start for protein production
we do codon optimization and
with a little bit of an extra
spin on it is that we
uh sprinkle in kind of uh uh
mad seven pam sites uh throughout the
genome so that uh pm pam sites for mad
seven are uh
aaa
and so
uh when available we kind of uh put
those uh pam sites into the in into the
codon optimized
gene as well
such that it then becomes allowable to
access any site along the gene uh for
for for editing um and then the final
thing of course is that we think about
is the terminator uh sequence and and
also what kind of of flanking sequences
that we might incorporate to
uh be able to
you know excise the gene later etc so
these are the type of
these are the type of things that we
think about when we're integrating a
gene into the genome to make it fully
accessible for the onyx platform
all right thank you again dr shepard our
next question
all the all the promoters and rbs's were
below the synthetic sequences uh
sequences used can you comment on this
yeah absolutely um
so
i had put uh all the
you know that i've made a library off
the online state um
used all the promoter sequences and all
the ribosome binding sites that are
found in e coli that then were
put in front of and replaced the
synthetic j-23 series promoter
and the
maximum rbs so the j-23 series promoter
it wasn't the
the
the highest strength but it was just off
the highest strength um so
if anything that those results
definitely clearly indicate that uh
those j23 series promoters did that the
uh ma the high expression ones are
very high
constitutive expression that the
ribosome binding site is indeed you know
uh pretty high now one thing that i did
uh on that particular application so far
was a very um
uh just uh
i had isolated and looked at just 192
colonies and so then
when we think about the plexity of that
library the plexity itself it ended up
being about 8 000
um
[Music]
a size of 8 000 different designs that
went into that library
so i was uh screening at a at a
just a very low depth um
of screening uh on a plate-based format
so
the uh
the promoters that i
you know accessed at that time uh ended
up being less than the than the high
strength promoter
uh i thought that that was rather
interesting too is is
a scenario where you know even with that
uh with that low depth screening uh
there were a few promoters that did
kind of rise up near to the uh j series
promoter uh so even at that low
screening depth there was some
interesting details i think that
particular application um
once we do a
cell sorting type workflow we might be
able to really identify if that holds
true for all of the promoters across the
e coli
or is it constrained to
just because only a few were tested
so thanks as a good question
all right thank you dr shepard our next
question here
these optimizations were in fairly low
throughput do you have any thoughts and
recommendations for increasing the
throughput to test more variants
yeah definitely
so
just as i
touched on there is is it was uh plate
based green is
is
already fairly uh fairly good at first
shallow sampling for
uh being able to
um
obtain
uh those which are trending upwards but
it's uh really interesting once you're
able to use a higher throughput
screening workflow
or
especially a selector's workflow where
you can really kind of dive deeper with
your with your library so
um
one of those you know methods which
isn't shown here is like cell sorting so
that would be available on a
fluorescence based approach um so with
cell sorting you know you can you can
kind of
sort based on the fluorescence and so in
the application that was shown here
where uh with the native promoters and
ribosome binding sites uh a cell sorting
experiment would allow for bending out
those fluorescences which have um high
high and low of fluorescence to be able
to look at
essentially the the entire population
so that's always great to to think about
when using these library
based approaches uh is you know what
what can you do in your workflow uh to
be able to kind of take advantage of all
the designs that are present in the 100
to 10 000 different designs that would
be available
for you to screen on
thank you dr shepard looks like we have
time for one more question
did you test the impact of other genes
on the production of this protein
um
yeah so that's
uh
if i understand correctly i think that's
that's an interesting question that's uh
getting at the concept of can you go
genome wide
instead of just looking at the genes so
so here this this application we i kind
of focus down on what you can do on the
gene once it's on the genome but that's
certainly very interesting is um could
we do like a genome white promoter or
genome white knockout series to actually
improve the overall expression of the
protein
uh that for sure
is addressed a little bit more with uh
with the the other app note that i
mentioned uh in in the cbh1 uh enzyme
protein production optimization where we
did go gene and white
uh here i have ambitions to take this to
genome white but it just became a bit of
an interesting little
side project to see what improvements i
could make to gfp itself
um so the you know you can suspect that
as you make improvements to the genome
there's going to be many different uh
chaperones that can be upregulated or
proteases that can be down regulated or
knocked out uh that we could really
boost the uh the actual protein
expression and that's something that you
know we're obviously very interested in
in trying to
develop those type of strains um with
with anyone so
thank you thank you again dr shepard for
your time today and for your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor in scripture for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye